finally a way out they've been stranded
here completely cut off since Sunday
when a fire storm - turned mallacoota
into a hellscape around a thousand
people signed up for evacuation this
family had sheltered from the blaze on
Year's Eve on the beach got to get away
from the said I hate life I think it's
coming true so yeah we worried about
what might happen again I'm the author
there's a maybe a potential that there
could be another bushfire so I've been
nice together so they're going out now
any sort of boat they can ferry loads
shuffling people to get out the way as
they come past after five days stranded
here this is deliverance
this was only the beginning of their
journey it's a 20 hour voyage to their
final destination well away from the
fires but they're in good care welcome
to board by the Navy thousands of others
are evacuating Victoria and New South
Wales
Saturday could bring fire conditions as
bad or even worse what we've seen so far
Victoria declared a state of disaster
the first in its history
it means authorities can't forcibly
evacuate people this is a ferocious fire
that is still out there and the climatic
conditions are going to be very
difficult to contain that in in the next
24 to 48 hours that's why the evacuation
messages are so incredibly important
those in mallacoota were told to bring
only the bare necessities aboard so they
did this nightmare is at least finally
over but there may be more to come the
landing craft made its way to the main
ship through a blanket of smoke the
fires are still burning
Tom Cheshire Sky News mallacoota